hello hello we are live live stream is
happening just going to wait a couple of
minutes for some people to connect and
then i will get started a lots going on
it's been pretty hectic couple of weeks
for the show and the timing of the
vacation and the upcoming trip
conference all that stuff i'll talk
about all of it and it's just all none
of it was by design and the timing with
relation to the YouTube ad boycott of
everything that's been going on has been
really coincidental so if this is your
first live stream first and foremost
answers to common questions number one
is this really live it is really live
unless you're watching a replay the time
is now 6 30 p.m. eastern time on april
twenty fourth 2017 if it is that time
then this is live and if it is some
other time then you were watching an
archived version of this live stream
number two super chat is on you can use
super chat that is the dollar sign
towards the bottom of the comment window
i guess it would be called and super
chat questions and comments will be read
answered if they are questions number
three new members and patrons get live
thank yous and shout outs during the
stream you can go to david pakman.com
slash membership to sign up for
membership and you can go to
patreon.com/scishow to become a patron
those are two different ways to support
the show we are independent media and
mostly audience supported particularly
lately and I will talk about that a
little bit more number four there are
moderators in the chat obvious trolling
and hate will get you banned
anti-semitism insulting other people
personally racism all that stuff just
don't do it it'll get you banned and
subtle trolling probably won't if it's
subtle enough that the great moderators
don't notice that so the okay so it's
been hectic at the show the last few
weeks on March 31st
we had the horrible horrible situation
with the YouTube advertiser boycott
we're all ads effectively stopped
playing on the david pakman show youtube
channel because a result of controversy
involving a Wall Street Journal article
about ads for big companies like
coca-cola supposedly appearing on racist
video something which really isn't the
problem I mean when you're serving
billions and billions of hours of videos
there are going to be anecdotal
instances where an ad plays on a video
that should not be eligible for
monetization but by and large it was not
a problem and that was really bad for
the david pakman show youtube channel
now we had a planned vacation for the
show april 12 to 20 i believe in april
14 to 20 and that was planned months in
advance so obviously the timing wasn't
great because we were dealing with the
youtube advertiser boycott but alas it
was planned so we did it and i will
update you on what happened with the
YouTube ad boycott during that time and
then in addition to that I was back in
studio today we did a full new show
today in studio but then I'm already out
again tomorrow Ben Dixon will be guest
hosting tomorrow because i'll be
travelling to Las Vegas to the mass
torts made perfect conference which is
my attorney and friend of the show Mike
Papantonio conference a number of
progressive media people will be there
including a sam cedar will be there who
else will be there i guess i don't know
but sam will be there and i go there
twice a year broadcast from there so i
will be broadcasting from there the rest
of the week just not tomorrow because
it's a travel day so it's been very very
hectic needless to say and the news has
not stopped I mean today on the show I
caught everybody up on the March for
science my view was the fact that
something called the March for science
even seems so necessary as to be as
successful as it was is actually really
scary the fact that the scientific
standing up and saying we should value
the scientific method that the fact that
that is even something to go protest
about tells us we're in pretty pretty
damn rough shape right now we talked
about Jeff
sessions wanting to arrest WikiLeaks is
Julian Assange on today's show I did
some of the more popular pictures from
my trip from my instagram account david
pakman we talked about the YouTube ad
boycott I'll follow up on that I talked
about the second Obamacare replacement
that we are expecting from Republicans
to get the full details of an analysis
of any day it's not looking good we also
talked about Dow Chemical donating a
million bucks to Donald Trump and now
wanting a pesticide study ignored I
talked about Bill O'Reilly being fired
for the same thing that donald trump
admitted to doing on video recording by
the way and also pointed out that Donald
Trump's hundred day approval rating is
the worst for any president since 1945
so it was a busy show and then on the
bonus show today Pat and I both talked
about our respective vacations during
last week's break so it was a busy show
busy bonus show and it'll be a busy week
of course the bonus show accessible
instantly to people who sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership and i told a number of
different stories related to my trip
some funny some more serious and i think
people will enjoy hearing about that let
me very briefly talk about a couple
breaking news stories that i won't be
able to talk about tomorrow on the show
since i'll be travelling but maybe ben
Dixon gets full control of the show when
he guest hosts and he might talk about
the story the entire US Senate has been
called to the White House for a briefing
on North Korea there's a CNBC article
about this telling us that top Trump
administration officials will be holding
a rare briefing on Wednesday at the
White House for the entire US Senate on
the situation in North Korea all 100
senators have been asked to go to the
White House for the briefing by
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
Secretary of Defense Jim mattis DNI dan
coats and General Joseph Dunford who's
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff it's common that administration
official
Elle's will go to Capitol Hill to
address members of Congress on foreign
policy and national security issues it's
much less common for the hundred member
Senate to go to an event at the White
House especially one where all four of
these secured a security officials are
involved so what's going to happen I
don't know one would imagine being
monday that if the situation in North
Korea were so urgent that military
action were necessary immediately to
protect national security that they
wouldn't schedule this for 48 hours from
now but again this is this is complete
and total speculation this is the Trump
administration after all which is sort
of fumbling around in the dark and who
on earth knows what it is that they're
thinking so I we don't know what to
expect but we will absolutely be talking
about that the briefing is at three p.m.
eastern time on wednesday so more than
likely we will learn about the outcome
around four or five eastern time on
wednesday which is after when the show
is produced so more than likely we'll
talk about the outcome of that on the
thursday show House aides said that they
are also working with the White House to
set up a similar briefing for members of
the House of Representatives so what
does this mean we don't know but it
probably is not the type of meeting you
call if you're just going to say hey
everybody we're not at all concerned
about North Korea and we plan to do
nothing thanks for stopping by right if
you plan something like this it's
probably because you have concerns about
North Korea and you plan to do something
so that is news that is breaking some of
the other top stories from the david
pakman show reddit discussion forum
which you can join at david pakman.com
slash reddit number one there are a
couple of articles including one that's
been posted to our reddit discussion
forum which are saying that the fox news
sexual harassment scandal may not stop
with just Roger Ailes and now more
recently bill o'reilly that sean hannity
maybe the next Fox News male to be taken
down by sexual harassment claims this is
an article from dead state org and it
alleges that Sean Hannity also has a
growing list of accusers when it comes
to sexual harassment and that would be
even more interesting because Bill
O'Reilly right wing persona was always
kind of bogus I mean we always sort of
knew that it's really it it was a
persona that he played on Fox News and
and it may not have been completely true
or genuine Sean Hannity on the other
hand the idea was we were led to believe
that when it came to sean hannity he
really was the completely upstanding
christian blah blah blah blah blah and
thus if we were indeed to learn that
sean hannity was wrapped up in this
entire thing i'm reading that morale is
very low at fox news right now that some
key executives just haven't been showing
up lately to work and that nobody knows
what the future is there and that things
are really really bad with a number of
50 advertisers being pulled from the
o'reilly show and it's not clear how
that's affecting Fox News's bottom line
more more broadly so we'll be following
that story also from the reddit
discussion forum a Washington Post
article has been posted called the
hotbed of anti-semitism isn't a foreign
country it's college campuses a new
report says I've been talking about that
issue for a couple of years I believe
that that is a major issue in the United
States anti-semitism under the guise of
you know progressive critiques of
israeli foreign policy have become
relatively widespread on college
campuses it's become very popular as a
pseudo progressive maybe putative lee
progressive litmus test and it's been
something i've been concerned about and
this is the washington post the same
washington post that has done excellent
critical reporting of the trump
administration connections to Russia etc
not exactly some kind of right-wing
bomb-throwing pub
pation has a report on this and I
encourage you to check it out it is very
very interesting and a lot of other good
articles there's a discussion on the
reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash reddit about the
Justice Department increasingly being
interested in going after WikiLeaks is
Julian Assange that's a story that made
it onto the show today very interesting
story it there's a lot there in terms of
what it means regarding a sort of red
line that you're crossing there's a long
history in the u.s. of going after
leakers and whistleblowers who are
taking or publishing information that is
classified or otherwise secret but that
typically tended to stop before it went
to pub going after prosecuting the media
publishers of that information and now
if indeed there is going to be
prosecution now whether anything could
happen right I mean Julian Assange has
been in the Ecuadorian Embassy in London
for a very long time there's no
indication that the new Ecuadorian
president has any interest in extradite
Assange but regardless if there were an
attempt made to prosecute Assange and
thus the actions at WikiLeaks that would
be crossing a red line and you could
argue well but David WikiLeaks isn't
exactly a media entity the way that the
new york times is that may be but
there's no doubt that wikileaks is not
the agency that obtained the information
they were given that a lot of those
documents by chelsea manning and that
would absolutely be a pretty big
crossing of a line that I would be very
concerned about in terms of what it what
it would mean for journalists so that's
a story that we talked about today an
article posted about the french election
to the david pakman show read it and i
didn't comment on the french election
today it is going to a runoff which is
going to take place i believe on May
seventh basically two weeks from the
date of yesterday's original election
marine lepen will be in that runoff and
I do not anticipate that will pen is
to win but we will absolutely be all
over that on may 8th it was a very very
busy show today so we did not get to
that there's also a very interesting
discussion started by Jay 473 on our
reddit discussion forum called why do
people hate Jews and it's a reaction to
the art to the piece we did recently on
the show by the same name or someone i
believe it was someone called in to the
show saying why do people hate so why do
so many people hate Jews I speculated a
little bit and it's it's it's actually
generally a pretty good discussion you
would anticipate that such a discussion
would bring in a lot of trolls and I
don't know if it's that the moderators
have been doing a good job of keeping
the trolling to a minimum or if that
people are actually taking the
conversation seriously but it's quite a
good discussion there that's going on
okay let's deal with super chat real
quick and then I'll talk about some
other other things that are going on ian
d sent a two dollar super chat how much
revenue have you made up with
fundraising so I've been advised by a
lot of people to be pretty careful in
terms of just anything related to
talking about YouTube revenue so I'm
gonna try to be very sort of careful in
my language patreon is a we're at
roughly 1,500 patrons on patreon and
that's given us a great jump on making
up lost YouTube revenue so that is going
pretty well and we're hoping to continue
growing that and we've seen a big influx
of members at david pakman.com slash
membership as well so how much of the
revenue has been made up it's not clear
we've gotten a great you know the first
ten days of the YouTube ad boycott saw a
really big move in the direction of
making up the lost revenue it sends you
know people get fatigued then even
though the YouTube ad boycott is still
going on people are getting a sort of
numb to the reality that it's going on
and thus the urgency of of membership
and of donating on patreon has has
probably gone down obeyed
a little bit and I anticipated that that
was going to happen so we're gonna have
to keep going I I mean I guess this is a
good a time as any to jump into what's
going on with the YouTube ad boycott so
the very quick summary is that on March
31st YouTube flipped a switch and turned
on and you add algorithm that determines
when ads play on YouTube videos prior to
march 31st the the average monetization
rate for our youtube channel with sixty
percent that meant that on average sixty
percent of the playbacks on our channel
had an ad that played for every hundred
thousand views that was roughly 60,000
ads that played on March 31st that
effectively went to zero I think it was
something like you know fifty monetized
views or something like that out of
hundreds of thousands of total views on
our channel so we were we were making
pennies basically what's happened since
then basically from March 31st through
april eleventh i believe it was the
channel made really no money other than
super chat money and a little bit of
youtube red money April twelfth and
thirteenth we saw a little bit of a bump
and I started to think okay well maybe
this is going to improve we may be made
something like twelve or fifteen percent
of what we had been making on youtube on
April twelfth and thirteenth and then
April 14th it just fell right back off
and and we've basically been at three to
five percent monetization so that's
that's roughly you know I'm sorry about
seven percent monetization which has led
to about three to five percent of the
revenue that we were making so it's
really really bad it's bad and I don't
know you know we saw a little bit of an
uptick on April 21st and 22nd and I
really don't know what's going on but we
the urgency on RN for replacing the lost
revenue hasn't changed because as this
thing is you know we were here and now
it's basically hovering between here and
here so whether it's three five seven or
nine
% of the revenue we used to have it's
still leaving ninety to ninety seven
percent of the revenue to be made up so
far so there's two ways that we're doing
that and there's really five ways to
support the show the the main ones are
number one and I don't know what
happened there looks like I lost that
hmm okay number one is that you can go
to patreon.com/scishow okay there's a
link in the description and we are
approaching 1500 patrons I've said
before that if and when we reach 2,000
individual patrons I will do an entire
show with my hair like this which is
what happens when I don't put any
product in my hair and this is a very
scary vision to some but I think it'll
be interesting if I did an entire show
in the studio like that so again we
started the stream with 1467 patrons
when we get to 2000 i will do a show
with my hair like that but regardless of
that this is very very democratic
because we are targeting a number of
patrons not an amount of money the goal
is two thousand so whether you can
pledge a dollar a month or two bucks a
month or ten bucks a month or whatever
we're going patron by patron and the
really important thing to consider here
is when YouTube was fully monetizing our
channel we estimated that if you watched
all of our videos every month all
hundred and sixty videos per month which
most people didn't but if you did we
were probably earning 35 to 50 Cent's
from your viewership so if you just
contribute a dollar you more than cover
what we lost from you as an individual
that's all I'm asking for just help us
replace those fifty cents and if you can
do a dollar you're basically covering
yourself and one other viewer and that
is already huge okay and while we've
been chatting here yo Keem to varun n
has pledged to dollars so we're now up
to 1468 patrons anybody who pledges
during the stream I will absolutely give
you a shout out and I thank you so
thanks to
kien the other option is membership okay
membership has a long laundry list of
benefits that you get including rather
than watching the three to five minute
youtube clips that we put up on our
YouTube channel every day usually around
four-thirty p.m. Eastern we put out the
full one-hour show from that day in one
video this is only available to members
so instead of waiting because we publish
each story about every 90 minutes
starting at four thirty you can skip all
that if you remember you get the entire
one-hour show sons commercials without
commercials right at four thirty p.m.
and we have a membership code which if
you go to david pakman.com slash
membership and select your membership
monthly or yearly you hit that red sign
up button on the second page under the
coupon code field if you were to type in
now you don't have to do this if you
want a forty percent discount off of
membership you can type in coupon code I
voted 17 and that will give you a forty
percent discount which I happen to think
is pretty cool okay so that's something
you can opt for or opt not to do but
it's fantastic either way because it's
helping us replace that lost revenue and
on that note tyler dennis has signed up
for a yearly membership at david
pakman.com slash membership also israel
aguayo has just pledged five dollars at
patreon.com slash david pakman show so
thanks to everybody who's been
contributing and signing up we are doing
it's a we're just grinding it out I mean
day to day we are doing what we can to
make up the revenue that we have lost
due to the YouTube advertiser boycott
and anybody else who either signs up for
membership or becomes a patron during
the stream I will sing your praises but
I'll get back to that in a little bit
okay a few other issues I want to talk
about the US Embassy in the United
Kingdom is promoting donald trump's
resort mar-a-lago on its
website so Trump is golfing or I guess
you watches cable news in the morning
the State Department is advertising
Donald Trump's private club in Florida
okay if you're an American your taxpayer
dollars are paying for this this is
totally unacceptable and I predicted not
that it took any amazing powers of
foresight but I predicted that because
there is just scandal after scandal
after scandal with the Trump
administration what under the Obama
administration were the biggest scandal
was he one day wore a tan suit when
talking about serious issues if
President Obama had done any of these
things if President Obama had a business
number one if he hadn't completely
cleared that conflict of interest before
becoming president Republicans would
have lost it but forget about that for a
second if the State Department was
promoting President Obama's private club
on its website it would have been 24 7
news coverage on right-wing media rush
Sean Hannity O'Reilly when he had a show
on fox news but because everything is a
scandal i mean it is scandal after
scandal with Donald Trump this is barely
this barely even registers and it is you
know you could call your representatives
about this it's not a bad idea you can
get in touch and say that this is
absolutely outrageous with a Republican
Congress and a Republican House is
anybody going to look into this I
genuinely am skeptical about that number
two there's an NBC News poll that shows
seventy-three percent of americans
currently back an independent
investigation into Russian election
interference now this is the wording of
this is different than an investigation
into Trump Russia collusion it's it's
slightly different and I think if worded
as Trump Russia collusion you would see
a lower number than 73 but this is
telling us that increasingly the Russia
scandal he
is a less partisan than just split down
party lines because you don't get
seventy-three percent of Americans
agreeing on anything if it doesn't cross
some party lines all right so that's a
very interesting poll and I'll probably
talk about it on the program we did a
story on the bonus show recently about
effectively what is a sort of detention
of gay men in Chechnya it has now been
discovered that there are four
additional off-the-record sort of black
site jails illegally it's not like this
is legal in Chechnya illegally holding
gay men those have been discovered the
Moscow Times calm is reporting on that
and this is a story that's gotten some
pickup we covered it pretty early on the
David Pakman show bonus show but it is
now getting more and more coverage and
it is stunning stunning that this is
going on and not in the usual places
where you would expect it although
really at this point I'm not you know
surprised about to too much fox news has
more problems than just sexual
harassment by men of women nine black
employees are now suing Fox News for
racial harassment Media Matters is
reporting on that we will probably
discuss that on the program upcoming
today is Armenian Genocide remembrance
day I get questions almost yearly about
whether I am an Armenian Genocide denier
and I genuinely don't know why number 1
i've never even suggested that I'm an
armenian genocide denier and number 2
i'm not like a big conspiracy guy and
the historical record is pretty clear
about the armenian genocide and i am on
the side of the historical record so if
anybody has any sense of why there are
regularly questions asked of me about
whether i deny the armenian genocide I
mean it's not the Armenian Genocide has
never been a big topic on our show but
that is not to me it wouldn't mean to me
that
the default the assumption would be that
I deny the armenian genocide by any
means by any means so no I do not deny
the Armenian Genocide let's take a look
at a super chat that has come in will be
my end sent a two dollar super chat what
did you think about yesterday's a glassy
go so in classical or the classic as it
would be translated from spanish to
english is when two spanish soccer teams
real madrid and barcelona play against
each other okay and it is a big rivalry
it also is a one that involves a number
of Argentinian men's national team
players of course i'm from argentina I
follow Argentinian soccer I don't follow
the the league with in Argentina but I
do follow the US or the Argentinian
men's national team pretty closely
barcelona won yesterday 322 i'm not cute
you know my i mean i'm a big leo messi
fan so it's sort of easy for me to say i
am a barcelona guy over real madrid but
quite frankly i just want to see a good
game and that that's my thing i don't
get too wrapped up one way or the other
but it's it's always interesting when
the two teams come together and i am i'm
sort of i've taught i guess this is as
good a time as any to talk about this
I've talked about feeling very very
mixed about the upcoming World Cups
because you know there's there's an
upcoming world cup in qatar and guitar
is a place that has major major human
rights issues and we also so 2018 is in
russia and 20 22 is in qatar 2018 in
Russia i mean i already and listen let's
not we've talked enough about Russia
let's not talk about Russia right now
hosting the world cup although yeah
probably there's significant corruption
going on also it's pretty much
undisputable at this point that there
was significant corruption in the
decision to host the
2022 World Cup and guitar number one it
is so hot in guitar in the summer that
might the latest i read was that they
are looking at actually hosting the
world cup in winter which is really just
a very forced and going out of the way
to go outside of the normal protocol
it's going to lead to players having
conflicts with their normal league play
in many cases i mean it's just a
disaster but the stadiums in qatar are
being built by effectively what we call
slaves right these are individuals who
go to qatar or happens in other
countries their passports are seized
their indentured servants or slaves use
whatever term you want that the human
rights conditions are just an absolute
disaster and I just I don't um I'm so
against the World Cup being in Qatar but
I love the world cup I really do and as
every it's only every four years that
outside of copa america and some other
smaller tournaments that i get to follow
the argentinian men's national team so
will i watch yes and I've spoken to dave
zirin about this numerous times about
whether we can whether it's morally okay
to watch the world cup but to advocate
for change and for solving the rampant
corruption within FIFA I don't know if
it's just because we want to feel better
about it dave zirin said that yes you
can watch the soccer games and still
advocate for change I guess I'm going
with that because you know makes me feel
a little bit better but maybe I
shouldn't be watching the world cup
maybe I should be boycotting I don't
know okay real quick say Cesar del Rey
has asked in in the comments David why
am I having moderators delete messages
from the opposition can't you handle the
criticism I can handle criticism the
moderators are deleting trolling
messages and I have full confidence full
confidence in the moderators to manage
that and I am seeing criticisms there
and in fact Andrew Duffy just sent a two
dollar and sixty-nine cents super chat
saying David is fake news and is bad for
America okay I mean if that was worth
two dollars and sixty nine
I don't think you're going to convince
too many people that we are fake news
watch our piece about fake news by the
way we have an excellent piece about
fake news which talks about the
difference between fake news and
propaganda news and you know if anybody
wants to want to point out if I've if
I've parroted any fake news during this
live stream by all means tell me Eric
and Nelson sent a five-dollar super chat
couple things number one who in the
Trump administration would you most want
to interview Donald Trump if it's not
Trump assuming that you mean not Trump
uh who else would that be I guess I'd be
interested in interviewing Kellyanne
Conway only because I think she actually
knows exactly what's going on and
realizes the absurdity but just hasn't
been able to talk about it because of
the position she's in and she's actually
imploded on air many times and now is
not doing media anymore but if I could
interview her having tea with her having
taken some kind of been given some truth
serum I would be interested in
interviewing her costume cinematography
Co has sent a five canadian dollar super
chat why is my apartment beige you know
it's actually not beige I think it's the
white balance of my camera and the
lighting because the lighting is
slightly yellow that makes it look beige
but the walls are gray the window sills
are white and shades are another white
there's actually the only thing that's
actually beige in this room is in this
art here let's see if I can point to it
the bottom and top bars of this piece of
art and I guess this lamp these this is
slightly beige and then over here that's
kind of a beige color but other than
that there's there's actually not beige
in this room which is interesting that
it looks that way I guess because of the
white balance that's going on okay let's
see what else we've got here in super
chat Andrew Duffy has again sent a two
dollar and 69 sent super Chet David is
not fake news
and is good for America okay so Andrew
Duffy very very quickly changing his
mind on that Clark 1234 sending a to
Australian dollar super chat any update
on the Spanish videos coming in may yeah
I've talked about that I'm generally
open to the idea of doing something in
Spanish and that there's probably a
pretty big audience for Spanish and
Spanish language political analysis of
American politics we're looking into
what sort of logistics might make that a
possibility it's complex I don't exactly
know yet what's going to happen but I
have not forgotten about it I have not
forgotten about it let me do a couple
thank yous okay number one as far as
patreon goes and we are targeting 2,000
patrons on patreon we have new pledges
we have a dollar pledge from stephen
role we have a ten-dollar pledge from on
DeAndre sir Cisco and the two-dollar
pledge from Jonathan McKinney that gets
us to 1472 patrons please please please
keep pledging during the live stream and
I will continue doing live shoutouts and
thank yous to people who sign up as far
as membership goes you can sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership normal
rates i think are very reads reasonable
you can get membership starting at six
bucks a month or sixty dollars for an
entire year which makes it like five
dollars a month but if those rates are
high and I understand that sixty dollars
or even six a month can be too much for
some people you can use the coupon code
I voted 17 and that coupon code will get
you a forty percent discount on the
second page of the signup process you
enter the coupon code I voted 17 that is
exactly what Nancy cranford just did
signing up for a yearly membership with
the coupon code I voted 17 very very
much appreciated Nancy I really
appreciate that so please keep it coming
and we will keep doing the live
shout outs and thank yous a couple of
other things that I want to mention we
did a story i'm already seeing in in the
chat talk about suppressing free speech
and you know all this stuff because
moderators are blocking people there's a
video that we did on our youtube channel
and let me get the exact name was it
banned or blocked how did we word it i
think it's like how likely is it that
you'll get banned they make sure how
likely are you to be banned and i
actually put up the number of people
banned or blocked on each of our
different social platforms including
youtube it is such an infinitesimally
small percentage of the people on our
facebook page my personal twitter
account my personal Instagram the show
Twitter account and youtube the
percentage of people that get blocked
your band is so low because we tolerate
so much it is only obvious trolling that
gets to the point of being a distraction
and really just just creating a negative
environment for people who are just
trying to watch what we're doing that or
it will get you banned that so please
don't come with that stuff almost nobody
is banned you really have to get our
attention in an incredibly significant
way for us to block you one other thing
a few people are talking about what's
going on with Venezuela we are in talks
right now to get how do I want to say
this I don't want to give away who it is
because it might not happen a very
important Venezuelan elected official on
the program okay this is someone that
I've been told by an intermediary that
knows them personally that this
individual has already agreed that they
would be willing to be on the David
Pakman show and at this point we're just
trying to work out logistics so that is
very very interesting to me because that
is a major story and we're going to be
talking about what
going on in Venezuela sooner than later
let's get to a few other super chats
here downstream 01 has sent a two
british pound super chat are you
planning on doing another video with
secular talk there's no plan right now
but I'm always up for talking to Kyle
and I would be up for doing a super chat
no doubt about it FML Romero has sent a
five-dollar super chat David it's good
to see that you are back it's good to be
back thank you very much clars 1234 has
sent a two australian dollar super chat
interview Tim pool and talk about an
tifa or antiphon I'm not sure how it's
pronounced yeah I'm up for interviewing
Tim I'm up for interviewing Tim that
would be that would be interesting he's
been his YouTube channel has been
growing growing quite a bit so I'm I'm
up for doing that we're right now I mean
people sometimes people are not totally
clear and why would they be of how far
in advance we book we book interviews
pretty far in advance sometimes I'll
tell you what's on the calendar right
now there's some really good stuff
coming up okay so today we were back
from being on break so I didn't want to
do an interview I wanted the full show
to just do stories to try to get caught
up tomorrow is my travel day I'm
traveling out to a conference in Las
Vegas where I will be coming to you live
from so Ben Dickson's guest hosting
tomorrow so no interview Wednesday and
Thursday will be doing a two-part
interview with Natasha Dowie shawl and
Natasha Dowie shawl is the author of
this book addiction by design this is a
really really good book about casino
design and machine gambling slot
machines digital slot machines and the
she's going to be great and how fitting
that i'll be talking to her about the
book she wrote based on research she did
mostly in las vegas when i am in las
vegas that gets us to the end of this
week next week on monday we will start
off the week with brian class who has a
new book called the despot sakam placed
is aiding
embedding the decline of democracy I
don't think I have to explain to you why
that's relevant right i think at this
point that's pretty evident and then
tuesday and wednesday we're going to do
a two-part interview with the great
richard wolf richard wolf an economist
who in retirement from teaching at the
university of massachusetts my alma
mater has become increasingly well known
but I've known him for I guess how long
wait at 2,000 I think I've known him for
like 14 years at this point which is
insane but he was my introductory macro
economics professor at the University of
Massachusetts the first college level
econ that I took on my way to subsequent
undergraduate and graduate degrees in
economics econ 104 was the class and
we've stayed in touch and he's been a
frequent guest on the show we are going
to talk with him about how what we've
observes are observed what we have
observed during the first hundred days
of trumps presidency is further evidence
that capitalism is not working in many
ways for many people right now I think
that is going to be very very
interesting and then on a fourth will be
speaking to Gordon Leigh fer who has a
new book called the one percent solution
how corporations are remaking America
ones day at a time very interesting
about a state control corporate control
at the state level ok so that's good now
we're booked even beyond that on may we
just confirmed this on may eight I
recently recommended this book this is a
book by a former FBI hostage negotiator
Chris Voss called never split the
difference negotiating as if your life
depended on it this is not an academic
book okay it's a very quick read and you
can get through it in a few hours it is
fascinating and we are going to talk and
this is amazing I told producer Pat hey
let's add chris voss the author of the
book former FBI hostage negotiator let's
add chris voss to our list of people we
want to interview and because we did a
segment recommending the book
his publicist actually reached out to us
saying we loved your recommendation of
the book do you have any interest in
interviewing Chris Voss to which the
answer was of course yes we just haven't
reached out to you yet but we absolutely
want to interview Chris boss so that's
going to be a two-part interview on may
8th and 9th and then we also already
have an interview booked for May
eleventh we're going to talk to Susan
Bordeaux about her book the destruction
of Hillary Clinton very interesting
about what's happened to Hillary
Clinton's political career and and what
if any future there is there and then
later in May I'll be interviewing
Elizabeth kurud halket who's the author
of this book which I have here the sum
of small things which is not about
Donald Trump's hands or other body parts
about him that that you might think of
as a result of the title of this book
but it is a theory about what the author
calls the aspirational class it's not
the upper class but it's the
aspirational class which is that could
actually spread across a number of
different economic classes and it
relates to inequality and a lot of other
things so really really good stuff
coming up really good stuff coming up
here and I think that it will be a good
month as far as interviews go and you
know what if you don't care about
interview some people just don't care
about the interviews that we do the
great thing is you don't have to watch
them you can just watch the other stuff
and and hopefully you will enjoy that as
well okay a few other thank yous to do
let's see Shane pro ler has just upped
his pledge at patreon.com slash david
pakman show from two dollars a month to
five dollars and fifty cents a month we
are attempting to replace the ninety to
ninety seven percent reduction we're
experiencing in YouTube ad revenue due
to what is known as the YouTube
advertiser boycott with something called
patreon patreon.com slash david pakman
show is where you can
check it out pledge and i will continue
live thank yous Wendy Martinez has also
become a member at david pakman.com
slash membership of course you can get a
huge discount off of membership forty
percent off by using the coupon code i
voted 17 at david pakman.com slash
membership also big thank you to Sonia
Rasmussen tim gray and elf prior alf
prior all of whom signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership during the
stream thank you thank you very very
much i really really appreciate that and
also thanks to everybody who has been
sending super chats during the stream
that we have had going on today a couple
of other things that are coming up on
the show that i want to talk about i am
looking into doing a few so many of you
are probably familiar with our long-form
segments okay we've been doing these for
at this point about a year and three
months many of them have been researched
produced and or edited by producer Noah
Ferguson who's been doing a heck of a
job I'm looking at doing what i would
call not a long-form piece sort of a
medium form piece so it wouldn't be like
a 20 or 25 minute piece but it might be
the type of thing where we take the
entire first segment of the show which
can range anywhere from you know 10 to
14 minutes and flesh out a topic like
for example here's one example I've
talked before about how there's
patriotism and nationalism that make
more sense to me and strike me as
healthier then the type of right-wing
patriotism and nationalism that we often
see related to you know the military or
just sort of amorphous claims about how
Great America is I think that there's a
lot there to flesh out and maybe a
12-minute piece people have asked when
I've suggested this before is this going
to be like a dave rubin direct message
not really it's not really going to be
that it's not going to take a sort of
monologue form but it'll be sort of a
longer time spent on one
topic and I've talked before about some
of these ideas pride in cities or a
well-functioning system of social
supports those are the things that make
sense to me to say this is what I'm
proud about about my country and a sort
of logical versus retrograde patriotism
is one idea that I have for that another
one would be nationalist versus
collectivist solutions I've talked a lot
lately in small bursts about how it
doesn't really were at a particular time
where the sort of nationalist ideas of
someone like Donald Trump make acutely
no sense given what's going on in the
world and that when we talk about an
issue like climate change pollution the
replacement of labor by automation these
are issues that go beyond imaginary
borders drawn on maps and delineated
with fencing around the world and that
were at a time where collectivist
solutions are actually more necessary
than ever this doesn't mean one world
government or Alex Jones type
conspiracies it just means a lot of the
issues that we're dealing with on this
planet lend themselves more to
collectivist solutions right now which
can still be administered by individual
countries I think that's another idea
another idea for a medium form piece
maybe a 12 to 14 minute discussion what
makes up a healthier media diet right
and a lot of this has to do with long
term versus short term news I'm making
the effort particularly with especially
the nonfiction books that I'm reading to
really spend my time reading about
issues that are going to matter beyond
just this month or even this year and
when I talk about the news that's going
on what are we talking about with
Obamacare or North Korea or whatever the
context should be how is this more
broadly going to affect us at a longer
term right and this gets away from sort
of gossip type journalism and I think
that that relates to the media diet that
the average news consumer can try to
sort of tailor and fine-tuned for
themselves so these are some of my ideas
for me
form pieces if you have other ideas by
all means let me know if you think this
is a terrible idea obviously let me know
as well Jules M has sent a ten-dollar
super chat what is the update on youtube
I heard something the other day and they
obviously downplayed how many people had
affected yeah so I did a brief update at
the beginning or sort of towards the
beginning of the stream a couple things
going on number one our revenue has not
come back we've seen we initially had a
99 effectively a hundred percent right I
mean we were making pennies a day
reduction in ad revenue on YouTube we
saw a return for two days earlier in the
month to about twelve to fifteen percent
and then it just fell off a cliff April
21st and 22nd which are the most recent
days I have data for we saw a tiny bit
of a spike may be back to like twelve
percent of what we had typically been
typically been making but we are down
for the month and we're already at the
24th of the month for the entire month
the channel is probably going to make
about twelve to fifteen percent of what
it normally does and a lot of that has
to do with the fact that some of the
live streams i did on april second third
fourth around there had a ton of super
chat revenue which has helped to make up
a little bit the lost revenue but from
ad revenue ad revenue this month will
probably be at about six or seven
percent of what it typically is so it's
bad it's really really bad we're doing
everything we can to raise money on
patreon to replace the lost income if
you can afford a dollar a month okay
this is not one of those situations
where you should say I can't do anything
big so I'll do nothing if you can afford
a dollar a month do the dollar a month
right now we have 793 people who are
pledging to dollars a month that's
nearly sixteen hundred dollars a month
from people who are only pledging two
bucks a month there's a lot of people
just pledging one dollar a month so
don't let the lack of ability to pledge
a ton of money stop you because the
whole idea is we're just trying to
replace what individuals were providing
by watching ads on our channel if you
watched every
on our channel in a month you were
probably contributing about 35 to 50
cents to us so all we're asking for is
just a dollar right just throw in a
dollar a month and if we get you know a
few thousand people doing that we're
going to be in really really good shape
the other thing we're still doing of
course and most people are aware of this
is membership you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we do an entire extra show
every day what you see on youtube is not
everything that is available we do an
extra show every single day for our paid
subscribers it's called the bonus show
and you can get access to that every day
if you become a member at david
pakman.com you can also use the coupon
code i voted 17 the normal membership
rates i think are very very reasonable
but they are too high for some folks and
that's okay you can use the coupon code
i voted 17 to sign up and i will
continue doing live shout outs and
thank-yous during the stream so that's
the latest update Jules I don't know
what will ultimately come of it but I'm
not hugely optimistic I'm planning for
the worst obviously I'm still hoping for
the best but I'm absolutely planning for
the worst aconite blossom has sent a for
canadian dollar super chat with no
question or comment thank you very much
I appreciate it clars 1234 has sent a
five australian dollar super super chat
add some stretch goals to the patreon to
give people more incentive to up their
donation also do a long-form piece on an
toughie and US cable news well the goal
right now is pretty stretched Clark
because we we are only at about a
quarter of the way to the goal even
though we've been running the patreon
now for more than three weeks so in a
way it is a stretch goal and I don't
know exactly what you mean as far as
more of a stretch goal but we're we've
been doing it for three weeks and we're
at a quarter of the way to the goal so
I'm not I'm not sure what you mean but
I'm certainly up for it if you send over
some ideas a lot of the stuff we do and
have done on the show is directly at the
sort of suggestion of the audience and
Clark's sang 6,000 do a Spanish video
7,000 Pat takes his shirt off are people
really interested in seeing Pat take his
shirt off is that something people are
interested in doing yeah i'd i'd
probably have to talk to pat you know I
don't want to have a situation where it
starts to become something like a sexual
harassment but I don't know it I guess
it's something that I can talk to talk
to the pad about but we're probably not
doing shirts off okay probably not doing
shirts off so that's that's what's going
on so far at today's live stream is not
going to be particularly long I have to
pack I have to plan a bunch of stuff as
I head out tomorrow to the conference in
Las Vegas mass torts made perfect with
Mike Papantonio sam cedar i'm not sure
if tom hartman is going to be around
this time but i am hoping to come to you
live i will be doing the show from las
vegas the rest of the week other than
tomorrow and i will also be hopefully
doing some live streams from Las Vegas
maybe sam cedar will join me on a live
stream maybe tom hartman will join me on
a live stream i don't know but i will
hope to do some of that stuff luca sent
a five canadian dollar super chat an
idea for a fundraising goal if you hit X
number of patreon patrons Pat has to
talk with the thick Boston accent we
know he has for an entire show yeah Pat
has talked about how depending on who
he's with his Boston accent was some
time to be noticeable I don't hear it at
all when Pat talks but maybe it will
come out I don't know but that's an
interesting one all right so on that
note that's it for now I will be
streaming again soon probably from las
vegas next time you hear from me